Esta visita era un sueño y tal vez
esperada por muchos en Ucrania pero
solamente esas sospechas empezaron a
hacer realidad esta mañana cuando las
calles de kiev la capital del país
fueron bloqueadas vaiden había anunciado
una visita para mañana para colonia
donde tiene planeado dar un discurso en
la capital Varsovia lo que hizo que
muchos sospecharan que estaban la ciudad
como luego Se confirmó se le dio
caminando en uno de los principales
plazas de la ciudad cerca a la iglesia
de San Michelle de las cúpulas doradas
donde él ya había caminado en el pasado
cuando había visitado Ucrania en el 2008
y años posteriores por allí había
caminado un lugar muy emblemático para
los ucranianos porque allí están
desplegadas miles de fotos de personas
que han muerto No ya desde que comenzó
la invasión el pasado 24 de febrero del
año pasado sino desde el 2014 recordando
que la guerra
Lleva más de ocho años ya cumple nueve
años con miles de personas que han
muerto el vino a comprobar ese
compromiso de Estados Unidos y de
occidente con Ucrania dijo que el país
se mantenía firme como también se
mantenía la democracia después de ese
ataque que intentó hacer el presidente
Vladimir Putin que su primera intención
era capturar el año pasado la capital
del país donde hoy caminaba el
presidente biden como dije anteriormente
él ha regresado a Polonia donde mañana
tiene planeado dar un discurso bastante
importante de apoyo a Ucrania hoy
confirmó que daría 500 millones de
dólares más en armamento especialmente
munición que sigue siendo pedida con
insistencia por no solamente por las
autoridades sino por los hombres por los
militares en el frente de batallas sin
embargo no habló de dar mayores armas o
diferentes especialmente misiles de
largo mayor alcance o nuevos aviones sin
embargo tienes espera
algo muy presidente Vladimir Putin hará
otro pronunciamiento importante desde
Moscú Así que mañana es un día bastante
importante para esta guerra que ya va a
cumplir un año en Ucrania Mientras tanto